chief intelligence correspondent
catherine herridge is that the Justice
Department tonight with details
good evening Catherine thank you Mike
the news conference here at main justice
was called with just 45 minutes notice
the indictment is powerful new evidence
of a Russian plot but does not name any
American co-conspirators the defendants
allegedly conducted what they called
information warfare against the United
States
with direct oversight of the Russia
Special Counsel probe the Deputy
Attorney General Ron Rosenstein said 13
Russian nationals and three Russian
organizations were charged with quote
conspiracy to defraud the United States
and illegally using social media to
divide Americans and disrupt the 2016
presidential election Russian
conspirators want to promote discord in
the United States and undermine public
confidence in democracy as early as 2014
the 37 page indictment alleges the
Russian defendants including Evgeny pre
gozen a businessman with deep ties to
Russian President Vladimir Putin and
their co-conspirators began planning the
operation from their base in st.
Petersburg Russia the indictment says
quote by early to mid 2016 defendants
operations included supporting the
presidential campaign of Van candidate
Donald J Trump and disparaging Hillary
Clinton the defendants pot server space
in the US to create a virtual private
network to hide the operations Russian
roots used stolen or fictitious American
identities fraudulent bank accounts and
false identification documents the
defendants posed as politically and
socially active Americans advocating for
and against particular candidates the
indictment alleges that Russian
operatives made contact with members
volunteers and supporters of the Trump
campaign they were unnamed in the
chargesheet the Deputy Attorney General
was asked if campaign officials were
duped there is no allegation in this
indictment that any American was a
knowing participant in this illegal
activity there is no allegation in the
indictment that the charge conduct
altered the outcome of the 2016 election
the Russian operatives allegedly sought
to hurt the candidacy of Trump's
challengers including Ted Cruz and Marco
Rubio and they allegedly aim to bolster
Hillary
challenger Bernie Sanders after the
election special counsel investigators
found Russian operatives played both
sides for example the defendants
organized one rally to support the
president-elect and another rally to
impose to oppose him both in New York on
the same day asked by Fox News whether
the Russian government would cooperate
in any future prosecution no
communication with the Russians about
this will follow the ordinary process of
seeking cooperation and extradition also
today a California man pled guilty to
selling bank account numbers to
Nationals outside of the United States
between 2014 and 2017 a spokesman for
the special counsel said they had no
evidence the man was a knowing or
winning participant in the Russian plot
Mike Catherine Herricks leading us off
at the Justice Department tonight
Catherine thanks very much